Let's take an actual segment of the ABO gene sequence here. From the coding
region, we're going to take all the sequence from position 793 to position
801. So we're in the ABO gene. There's sequence on either side of
this, but I want to focus in on this little snippet here. The TACCTGGGG.
Now let's imagine that this is part of a
DNA coding region in the ABO gene, and that
it's going to be turned into protein, and the codons
would be red like this, where we're in frame, we're
reading along and we had a codon, a codon
and a codon. I want you to imagine that
you're a ribosome. An you were going to translate this
sequence. So what would be the amino acids produced from
this DNA sequence from the coding region of the ABO gene.
I want you to use your genetic code, and look for
the one letter abbreviations of the amino acids, and put what
answer you think it would be in this text box here.
Remember, this is something you're going to need to use your
genetic code for, which you can see in a miniaturized version
here. But, you can also get it in a link, located
in the instructor's notes on this page. It's probably a good idea
to go ahead and print this off and keep it handy somewhere, as we're going
to keep coming back to it throughout
other exercises in this lesson and other lessons.